[音楽]
[拍手]
何がめでたいんだかねえ分からなかったと思うんですが
8気持ちいいもんですね a 人生でこんなに大勢の方にですね
おめでとうなんて言われることはねそうそうないかと思います
なので申し訳ありませんがもう一度だけちょっと言っていただいていいですかね大丈夫
ですかね心の準備大丈夫ですか
あの隣の方に迷惑かからない程度でいいので
えちょっと大きめの声でね言って頂けると嬉しいなと思います
それじゃないですかせーのっ
ありがとうございますえーちょっと見ていただきますと実はですね僕は46年前の今日
12月の4日ですね
母の中の中で首にへその緒が巻きつきですね
仮死状態でこのように取り出されました
僕は父の顔も名前も知らずに栄養消去を育ったわけですがすごいですよね
を遠坂家お父さんなかったですねお母さんとかね
またおじいちゃんおばあちゃんたち口うちに言うんですよね
同じことを言うんですまたあの隣近所のじいちゃんおばあちゃんたちもですね
全く同じことを言うんですよまあこの大人の団結力ってすごいなぁと思うんですけど
あなたのお父さんはアメリカに出張に行ってるよってみんな言うんですよ
あのー
少し離れたねところに住んでいる知り合いとかもね
聞いてみても同じことでしょあなたのお父さんアメリカに出張で行ってるんだよね
みたいな感じでねほんと機にもっと南団結力ってすごいなーって
子供ながらに思ったのを覚えていますうわぁ小中校とですね僕は
に書いたような不登校ですもう本当に人の3分
1入ってますかね6332円そのうちの3分の1入ってるか入ってないかだと思います
まあ当然大人になってからも職を転々としました
市の嘱託職員から始まりましてへ
住宅の解体まあをがただのダンプとかですね
10禁に乗ってあの9会場のすぐ裏なぁの音建物も壊した記憶があります
まあをと寒い中猫はさせて頂いたなぁなんてねちょっと懐かしく思いながら先ほどね
眺めていました
まあそんな中でですね当然そういう仕事についているかなと
そういうことではないです人様に迷惑かけることはたと ap 行ってきましたねー
もう皆さんにお伝えできるような音内容のことではなかったかなと思うんですそれでも
本当こそね
僕も人の役に立ちたいなあってそんなふうに思いました
まああの
そうですね今ぼく整体師という仕事やらせてもらってるんですけど僕の様々な経験の中
例えばですねえええ元嫁です宇津戸丸
また
離婚を経験しましたそんな中僕は2人の娘を一人で育てたわけですがそんな娘もつい
先月ですね一人
長女ですね入籍いたしました
またちょっと事情はね事情がありまして和歌山の大学に行っております
まあ元気で頑張ってくれてるとは思うんですけども後ほど内容を話しさせていただき
ます
そんな経験とまた整体師としてお客様の体を見させていただいている中で気づいたこと
それが今日のテーマです
人は思い込みの中で生きている言葉の便利さに気付いてほしい
これが今日のテーマです
人は思い込みの中でたくさんの思い込みの中で生きています
例えばですけど皆さんに簡単な質問をしていきます
もうしていきますので隣を見てですねとなりの方が上げているから私もあげようかなと
か
この質問を僕私があげちゃったらちょっと恥ずかしいかなとかそんな話です
いいですかほんまに秒であげてください人間の脳はそれができます一瞬の情報が入った
だけで人間っていうの反応ができるんですね
感が経てば経つほどいろんな状況とかそういうものに関わりを持たせようとします
なのでコンマ2秒でいきます心の準備大丈夫でしょうか
前田の方の頭叩かないようにしていただいてですね挙手をお願いしたいと思います
いいですかねでは質問していきます
自分は
積極的だと思ってる人
ありがとうございます消極的だと思ってる人
ありがとうございますこの会場に歩いて入ってきた人
がとうございます
自分は断固だと思ってる人
ございます自分は中途半端だと思ってる人
ありがとうございます自分は天才だと思ってる人
ございます
おめでたいですねはい
まあそんなことでですね実はいくつか今質問させていただきましたが現実真実っていう
のはたった一つだけなんです
たった一つです
お分かりですか
今質問した中で現実真実っていうのは9日以上に歩いて入ってきた人という質問させて
いただきました
これ以外はすべて覚え込みです
信じられますか
ですか
例えばですね頑固だった人へお聞きした時に手を挙げられた方
結構いらっしゃいましたん
でもどうでしょ
元この人がですね僕が手を挙げてくださいって言ったら手を挙げるでしょうかね
いやわしは絶対あげようとか私絶対あげない婆とか
檀家の人そうじゃないですかねぇ
あげていただいた素直な方なので実は思い込みの中でね
私は頑固だと思い込んだといいですね
また中途半端だと思ってる人っていうところでよしお願いしますよね
あげられた方ご自身が得られたんでわかってらっしゃるかと思うんですけど
大丈夫ですかちょっと足元見ていただいていいですかズボン膝までしか上げてないよ
それでここの会食しちゃったわーとか
女性大丈夫ですかねぇ
鏡を持ちだったらちょっと見てみてください右判明しか
化粧してないなぁとか
左側しか松江つけてくるの忘れちゃったとかそんな方いらっしゃらないと思いますよね
僕はのこの18分間いただいてますけどちょっと皆さんのこと心配なので
今中途半端だとね思ってるっていうところに手を挙げた方ちょっと時間差し上げますの
でね
足元とかね顔ちょっと確認してみてもらっていいですか大丈夫ですか
みんな皆さんいろんな佐陀町いいですよ大丈夫ですねなのでこれもね
そんなことはないんです皆さんバッチリメイクされてズボンもちゃんと腰まで上げてね
この会場にいらっしゃっているかと思いますね
まぁこんなようにね人は思い込みの中で生きちゃってるんですよね
もう一つ
みなさんメリーさんの羊と言うたご存知ですか
ご存じですかね
メリーさんの羊ちょっと皆さんの猫柄をね
聞かせていただきたいと思います
あの今歌ってくださいってお願いしました
この瞬間にね私音痴だからとかねそんな風に思われた方
これもすべて思い込みですよ大丈夫です
オファーされる時に音て外されないですよね
大丈夫ですねイントネーション変わったりとかしないですよね
ということは歌を歌われでも音痴っても発生しません
なので遠慮なくですよ隣の方たちに遠慮なく声も高らかにね
1番だけでいいのでメリーさんの羊ちょっと歌ってみてもらっていいですか
ちょっと思い出してもらっていいですかね1番の歌詞を思い出してみてください
いいですかじゃあ皆さんでねこういうも高らかに
お願いをいたします123入っ
[音楽]
さん
ありがとうございますあのさハイ最後はね皆さんねありがとう6ですかね
えーと今ねメリーさんのひつじひつじひつじと謳われた方どれ位いらっしゃいますか
挙手をお願いします
大半の方のそうですよねはいそれ以外の歌詞で歌われた方ちょっと声いただいていい
ですか
赤い
用洋服のかだ
ねえ飯辻はいありがとうございますじゃあ8例えばですね命名出自と謳われた方
いらっしゃいましたら挙手をお願いします
はいありがとうございます本当に少数ですよねあの実はですねへメリーさんのひつじの
歌詞は
ひつじひつじじゃないんですねメリーさんの羊
命名出自なんです先ほど教えていただいた方ね
本当に大正解です
あの今日はちょっとねワケ有りましたねこちらの方にはねあの箇所を脱することができ
ないんですけども
ちょっと検索して見ていただいていいですかねメリーさんの羊店歌手が出てきます
どんな歌詞なのかっていうのでちょっと確認してください
これもどうですか間違った箇所皆さんね覚えちゃってるわけですよね
どなたにおそ
あったでしょうかねおじいちゃんおばあちゃんに教わった方
またお父さんお母さんに教わった方また学校で習った方とかね
入ったへ様々だねあのー
伝わり方でね皆さん覚えちゃったかと思うんですけどそれは今度皆さんが例えば他の人
に伝えちゃってるんですよね
間違った歌詞を相知教えちゃってるんですよね
これはちょっとまずくないですか話ですよね
なので今日この会場に来ていただいた a
一つのお土産としてですねメリーさんの羊は実は執事羊じゃないんですね
命名室ジーっていうのは正しい歌詞だっていうのねお持ち帰り頂けたらなと
そんなふうに思いますはい
またですねー
僕は高精細4をやっていまして
感じることってたくさんあります
言葉の大切さですねあの人間というのはええええ
今どうでしょう言葉たまあとか音霊とかね大切なんだよってことね
お話よく聴いている方いらっしゃると思うんですね
例えばですけどん
人間ってストレス社会で現代社会というのはとストレスまみれていて
悩み事がたくさんあるんだよってね皆さん悩みを抱えていらっしゃるかと思います
そんなときどうでしょ皆さん
どんなふうにしてそのストレスを変えようとか回避種を溶かしてますかねえ
多くの方は男性特に多いですかね
酒でも飲もうかなとか
女性は多いでしょうかね甘いもの食べようかなとかね
あとはどうでしょう買い物にでも行ってみようかなとか言うかたね
結構声を聞いたことがあるんですねでも実際どうでしょうねぇ
仕事中会議中ちょっと想像してみてください
会議中仕事中にですねお酒飲むことできますか
玉がしにくいと思いますね甘いものは若干ねー
食べれるかと思うんですけど手元になければ海に出なければいけないですよね
行動しなければいけません
でも言葉って常に自分が持ち歩いてるんですよね
24時間365日常に自分の身体と一緒に動いてます
言葉に出さなくてもですね頭の中でその言葉を思い浮かべたりとかするだけで気分が
変わったりとかですね
気持ちが落ち込んだものが少し上がったりとかするっていうこと金あるんですね
僕の場合この言葉です嫌なら辞めちまえ自分という言葉です
どうでしょ1件この言葉ってきつく感じませんか
嫌なら辞めちまえ自分
これは僕自身が僕に問いかけるから響く言葉なんですね
周りの方たちにこの言葉を言われた時その時の自分の状況によって捉え方というのは
変わってきてしまいます
言葉ってここが強いんです
誰か他の人に言われた時に違うものに感じてしまう
そのときの自分の心の持ち方在り方によってどうしても捉え方が変わってしまうんです
ね
なので僕はこの言葉を自分自身に問いかけます
嫌なら辞めちまえ自分
先ほど僕を話しましたえ
字上の話です今現在和歌山の大学に行っています
ある時ですね娘からラインが1本飛んできました
ん
パパ今電話していいかなーっていう文面でしょ
僕時間あったのでいいよって返しました
数分を娘からの電話です
まぁいつもの通りにもしもし同社
こんな感じで娘に話しかけました
車
すると娘は
中秋の向こう側で
言葉を詰まらせ涙声だったです
パパ助けてよもう限界だよって
この言葉ものすごく僕の心を打ちました
和歌山って遠いです
すぐに飛んでってあげたくても飛んで行くことができませんでした
ん
娘は教職でした
体重32キロを切ってました
医者に緊急搬送された時には
生命の危機だと言われましたん
それでも娘は一人でがむしゃらに頑張ってきたんですね
そんなことも知らずに僕はこの長野県で暮らしていました
すぐにでも飛んでってなんとかしてあげたかったです
でも
いけないんです
僕が何とかしてあげようとしても娘の虚飾が治らないです
本当に悩みました車
でもそのときにこの言葉です
嫌なら辞めちまえ自分っていう言葉 follow 僕は自分に問いかけました
どんな状況の中でも苦しい中でも
この言葉を僕は何かけたら自分が少しアップできるんです
落ち込みすぎずに済むんです
僕は今日みなさんにこの言葉を覚えて帰って欲しいわけじゃないんです
自分自身が自分自身に問いかけた時に
気分が少し上がれる言葉
気分が良くなることがそれに皆さんであってほしいんです
自分の内側に目を向けてください
人というのは大飼他人出来事単位
環境ですこの3つに同士を接着しているので外へ外へ
目が向いてしまいます
自分の内側に目を向けてください
そして自分が心地よくいられる言葉
これに出会ってみてください
僕はそれを今日みなさんにお伝えしたいと思います
ここで僕も製材しをやっておりますので皆さんに
ワークを一つやっていただきたいと思います
ただ会場どうしても階段状のため安全確保をしていただければなければいけないと思い
ます
皆さんちょっとを勝ちいただいてよろしいですかご協力お願いします
やっていただくことはあ
前屈です
全靴をしていただきますなので階段状ですので下に転げ落ちないようにご注意いただき
ます
横を向いていただいた方がいいですかねはい私くお願いします
ただちょっと間をあけていただいてぜひとも行っていただきたいと思います
はい
常日頃皆さんは自分自身ね内側に目を向けるってことが少ないかと思います
自分がこの会場に来られたのも自分がここに足を運んで来れたら来られたもう自分の体
があってこそですよねなので自分の心
内側に感謝の気持ちを伝えてほしいんです
うその前にちょっと今の自分の体の硬さを前屈で確かめてみてください
お願いします
片方方もね柔らかい方もいらっしゃると思います
腰痛終わりの方塗りしないでくださいねはいありがとうございます
ありがたいんですよねハイあのちょっと僕
彼ねちょっと観ていただいてですねまず自分自身を抱擁してください
肩をそっと抱いてください
そして自分に自分ですよ自分の内側にですね自分に対して感謝の気持ち
それが
ありがとうです
ありがとう自分自身に豪快
伝えて下さいお願いします
はいありがとうございます
じゃあもう一度すいません前屈してみてください
どうでしょう体が柔らかくなってませんか
地面までの距離が近くなっていると思うんです
どうでしょうね
私の柔らかくなりましたね打ち合わせ通りありがとうございますありがとうございます
ありがとうございますみなさんご協力いただきましょうありがとうございますではご
着席ください
ありがとうございました a こういうね言葉っていうのはすごく大事です
またありがとうっていう言葉の音すごく大事ですっていうのはね
たくさんの方がなた方々がねえ皆さんにお伝えしているかと思います
例えばですねこのありがとうっていう言葉を1日1回でいいです自分が頑張った自分が
ですね自分自身に
心を込めてですね言ってあげてください
それだけで自分の身体は変わってくると思います
僕が今日みなさんにお伝えした思い込み
これに件皆さんにお持ち帰りいただきます恒心会出席される方はその後で構いません
出席できない方はその後でかまわないのであと3つぐらい自分がどんな子と思い込ん
でるか自分の内側に目を見てみてください今日はあれど
ざいました
[拍手]